Est-ce que c'est pas le moment pour une petite vidéo thread là bah oui allez on y va tout de suite ça fait longtemps
qu'on a pas fait de thread mais pourquoi ça fait longtemps parce qu''y à pas de thread incroyable ces derniers temps on va pas
se mentir
aujourd'hui ça parle pas d'une histoire
paranormale d'un lieu hanté de je sais pas quoi ça parle d'une putain d' enquête criminelle qu'un tweetos à mené seul lourd ou pas
ahhh ils sont pas chauds aujourd'hui il s'agit d'un thread espagnol décidément les espagnols mecs ils sont hyper chauds en thread c'est abusé ils écrivent trop bien
et comme à chaque fois qui dit thread espagnol dit traduction par Lorraine merci Lorraine
j'adore ces petits running gag de remercier Lauren
alors que je la déteste dans la vraie vie vous allez voir c'est très
intéressant je vais juste vous dire les trois premiers tweets du thread et vous allez être à fond dans ce incroyable tout commence quand sur
twitter un utilisateur du nom de plot-tuit
s'adresse à la police en disant qu'il vient de résoudre un crime à travers twitter et qui demande qu ils prennent ça très au sérieux
il apporte une petite précision en précisant que le mec au milieu de la photo est décédé attention spoil
il s'appelle Jorge voilà petit spoil et que l'affaire a été fermée comme un suicide
alors qu'il s'agit d'un meurtre et qu'il peut le prouver deuxième précision le tueur est sur la photo et ça y est vous êtes à
fond dedans et maintenant on est chauds allez c'est parti on y va son enquête commence par une simple visite sur le twitter de Jorge
surprise sur cette page twitter peu de tweets et aucune photo et dans sa bio twitter petites infos importantes
comme Jorge.A grâce aux initiales plot-tuit il a réussi à trouver les événements racontés dans un article d'un journal de la région apparemment
Jorge se serait suicidé par défenestration
alors il est revenu sur la page twitter de Jorge et il a tchéké un peu tous les tweets qui s'y trouvait est à la recherche
d'indices de quelque chose sur sa vie qui aurait pu le mener à ce suicide et il est tombé sur un tweet intéressant qui dit la
chose suivante parfois en s'aime pour rien parfois on se blesse pour rien
hummmm serais-tu en peine
sentimentale Jorge plot-tuit avance dans son enquête il se dit putain mais Jorge était peut-être en plein chagrin d'amour et peut-être que ça a quelque
chose à voir avec les deux autres mecs qui sont sur l'image d'après la légende de la photo elle aurait été prise quelques heures avant
l'événement donc le suicide de Jorge dans une discothèque dans le centre de Barcelone
il est donc possible que l'élément déclencheur ait eu lieu à ce moment là dans cette boîte de nuit avec ces deux personnes sur la
photo en plus de Jorge, Jorge semblait en plus traverser une période difficile de sa vie à d'autres tweets qui indique qu'il n'était pas bien
notamment un juste avant d'aller dans cette fameuse boîte de nuit vers 3 heures du matin et qui dit aucun désir je vais essayer à
nouveau un dernier effort
essayer quoi au
juste plot-tuit a ensuite vu que sur l'image y'a quelqu'un qui était identifiée
qu'il s'agit du garçon en rouge à gauche dans la photo il a donc pu se rendre sur son compte twitter pour avoir plus d'infos
sur ces gens et sur peut-être ce qui s'est passé lors de cette soirée mauvaise surprise
il n'y a pas de tweet sur son compte twitter mais bonne nouvelle quand même il avait rempli sa description de page twitter et y'a
une info c'est qu'ils les graphiste mais le gros truc louche surtout c'est que Felipe et Jorge ne se suivent pas sur twitter plot- tuit le
dit lui même comment peut-on paraître autant amis sur une photo et pourtant ne pas du tout semblé l'être sur les réseaux sociaux il va
donc se mettre à penser que peut-être y at-il entre ces trois personnes un triangle amoureux c'est possible il y'a de la jalousie
de l'amour mais aussi de beaucoup de sentiments négatifs qui peuvent pousser à un suicide
où à un meurtre alors plot-tuit tourne un peu en rond j'ai dis plot-tuit au moins 18 depuis le début de la vidéo c'est insupportable
et à force de regarder la photo qu'il a mis en fond d'écran sur son ordinateur
tellement il fait un blocage sur cette histoire il remarque qu'il y'a une truc bizarre avec le tatouage de Jorge alors à première vue y'a rien
d'anormal c'est juste un tatouage de kéké où il y'a marqué liberté euhh dans une typo un peu dégueulasse
pardon si certains ont le même tatouage non je suis hautain mais c'est vrai merde quoi marquer freedom en gros sur son bras ça va deux minutes mais
là où il ya quelque chose de bizarre c'est que quand on regarde le tee-shirt de Felipe qui est donc à gauche de l'image
on remarque facilement que les lettres sont à l'envers parce qu'ils sont face à un miroir et donc sa retourne l'image à l'horizontale
un peu comme ça
voilà exactement comme ça mais du coup pourquoi le tatouage lui n'est pas à l'envers c'est chelou il devrait être comme ça sur la
photo il devrait pas être droit du tout ou alors il a tatoué freedom à l'envers exprès pour qu'on puisse lire le mot uniquement quand il
est devant un miroir
bizarre mais quitte à faire un tatouage de kéké autant ajouter un truc original ahh pardon je...je suis pas objectif quand on va sur
le profil twitter de Jorge on peut trouver une photo de son tatouage et on peut clairement voir que le freedom n'est pas du tout
marquée à l'envers une seule conclusion possible la photo a été retouchée
ehh mais on n'avait pas petite info la sur..euh...ahhhh le graphiste si quelqu'un a retouché la photo
c'est forcément lui il est graphiste il serait donc totalement capable de
photoshopée une photo pour y ajouter un tatouage et autres
informations importantes c'est pas Felipe qui a posté la photo sur twitter mais c'est Luis le mec de droite sur la photo ce qui veut
dire que si la photo a été retouchée avant d'être publiée sur twitter
Luis et Felipe sont complice plot-tuit se
met direct à imaginer des scénarios un peu macabre des scénarios dans lequel Jorge se serait fait tuer par
Luis ou Felipe et Felipe et Luis s'arrangent pour publier une photo fake de eux en boîte avec Jorge pour faire comme s'ils étaient très amis et
ce jusqu'à la veille du suicide de Jorge il y a des gens dont on n'a pas parlé depuis le début de ce thread c'est
les gens qu'il y'a dans le fond sur la photo ils étaient à cette soirée ce jour là eux aussi ils pourraient peut-être nous donner plus d'infos comme
par exemple confirmé le fait que la personne au milieu de la photo n'est pas Jorge et que c'est bel et bien quelqu'un d'autre qu'on
a
photoshopée pour y ajouter le visage et le tatouage de Jorge Plot-tuit a été très malin la seule info qu'on peut avoir sur...euhh
ces deux personnes c'est sur la personne de droite on voit un morceau de son tee shirt et en augmentant très fort la luminosité de
l'image on peut voir un petit motif à paraître qui correspond à celui d'un tee shirt adidas vous savez le 3
Plus simple
il va donc fouillé les comptes twitter de nos trois protagonistes dans l'espoir de trouver une autre photo sur laquelle il y aurait ce mec qu'on reconnaîtrait grâce
à son t-shirt adidas en espérant qu'il soit identifié sur la photo et qu'on puisse donc le contacter grâce à son compte twitter et bingo
Luis a aimé le tweet d'un gars qui postait juste une photo de lui et son t-shirt et ben ya clairement le logo adidas dessus
donc c'est lui le putain de mec sur la photo et donc on à son compte twitter c'est magnifique notre enquêteur malgré lui décide de le
contacter pour obtenir des informations salut désolé de te déranger on se connaît pas mais j'ai une question sur une connaissance de Jorge
clairement un gros mytho et pourquoi pas il mène son enquête il a raison le garçon qui s'est donné la mort samedi matin je connaissais
pas énormément de fait j'habite à madrid mais nous nous sommes déjà vu quelques fois j'essaie de récolter des infos car je tourne un peu
en rond sur ce qui s'est passé à putte un ouais je comprends je suis très touchée aussi on se connaissait pas c'est bien que
ça c'était seulement un ami dhabi mais je suis quand même choqué personne ne s'attendait à ça
ce qui m'intrigue le plus c'est pourquoi a-t-il commis une décision pareille juste après avoir pris cette photo avec luis et felipe
t'as une idée ce qui a pu se passer entre eux comme je te le dis je les connais pas si bien que ça
mais chez que luis et georges ont été ensemble pendant un temps
ooooooh
mais ça fait genre plus d'un an qu'ils sont séparés en fait je crois que louis c'est avec felipe maintenant
Mais ils doivent quand même être potes pour se prendre en photo comme ça non tu te souviens de ce moment ou pas tu étais
présent ce soir là c'est bien toi le garçon fond de la photo
putain j'avais jamais vu cette photo mais c'est bien moi je savais pas non plus que jorge était là dans la boîte mais en même
temps j'ai peu de souvenirs
j'avais un peu bu j'étais fatigué à cette heure là je me souviens plus de grand chose mais je suis sûr que kapoor attendait un
peu plus c'est le mec qui est à côté de moi il a beaucoup moins vu que moi donc il subit forcément de plus de
trucs il a pas twitter mais je te laisse son ulti peut joindre sur what's app attend
georges était donc en couple avec luis mais maintenant luiz est en couple avec felipe
moi si j'étais george j'aurait un peu le seum à en juger par les tweets de georges aucun désir je vais essayer à nouveau on en
conclut qu'il sait pas vraiment remis de sa rupture avec luis et qu'il a donc logiquement le seum contre felipe le nouveau mec de luis
alors là on commence à accumuler beaucoup d'infos donc plot-tuit il est mignon et nous met un petit schéma qui résume tout ce qu'on
sait pour le moment le mec de gauche c'est felipe donc probablement celui qui a retouché la photo le mec du milieu c'est georges mais
c'est du bullshit on sait que c'est pas georges et que son visage a été modifiée le mec de droite c'est lui le mec qui a twitter
la photo derrière eux se trouve à gauche carles et à droite quim
le mec à qui on vient de parler et donc la seule piste qui nous restent actuellement bas c'est de parler à carles et lui
demander s'il a vu georges ou pas et bien plot-tuit il perd pas de temps "hello désolé de te déranger on se connaît pas c'est quim qui
m'a donné ton num je suis une connaissance de georges le garçons qui est décédé samedi je le connaissais pas très bien mais on s'est vus
plusieurs fois j'ai besoin d'avoir des infos sur ce qui s'est passé c'est pas toi la personne au fond sur cette photo si c'est moi
je me souviens bien de ce moment mais je n'étais pas là elle sort d'où cette photo putain c'est dingue
elle vient du twitter de luis sérieusement je sais pas c'est quoi ce bordel mais je peux jurer que georges n'était pas là
et boum Jorge n'est donc bel et bien
jamais allé à cette putain de soirée où était georges et pourquoi felipe et louise ont voulu faire croire qu'il était là en boîte avec
eux là notre sherlock holmes made in espagne galère un peu et tourne en rond mais il ya un truc qui peut nous
donner des infos et qu'on n'a pas relevé sur la photo attention essayer de deviner
La montre de felipe mon pote la photo ayant  été prise dans un miroir il suffit de la retourner et ensuite on obtient l'heure
exacte à laquelle la photo a été prise cette nuit là et c'est plutôt clair à peu près cinq heures 55
les articles sur georges disent qu'il est décédé à 5h30 comment aurait-il pu être en boîte à
5h55 ça confirme donc
définitivement le fait que la personne au milieu de cette photo n'est pas george mais quelqu'un d'autre à qui on a ajouté un tatouage sur
le bras et à qui on a ajouté le visage de george mais alors à qui appartient ce corps putain un truc qui pourrait nous
aider à savoir si le gars du milieu est complice c est ce qu il a essayé de s'habiller comme
georges le jour de sa mort bingo dans l'article qui parle du décès de georges il est bel et bien spécifié qu'il portait un polo
noir comme le mec de la faute au milieu ils ont donc vraiment voulu faire genre que c'était georges sur la photo et là vous
êtes en train d'errer dans vos écrans vous vous dites mais c'est qui le mec au milieu sec et alors on va recontacter cars pour
lui demander plus d'infos sur ce mec du milieu
salut désolé de te déranger encore une fois tu te souviens du mec à qui ils ont pris la photo
pas vraiment je vais pas trop prêter d'attention mais j'ai vu passer 2 3 fois c'est un mec normal du même âge que les deux
autres et je n'ai pas vu de la soirée jusqu'à ce moment je me souviens d'une chose il avait les yeux bleus et les cheveux
bruns et je crois qu'il était étranger merci
il ya une grosse interrogation dans l'histoire c'est pourquoi ont-ils eu besoin de faire semblant que george est allé en boîte de nuit l'une des
raisons valables ça aurait été de mettre des bâtons dans les roues aux policiers qu'ils essaient de reconstruire le parcours de georges
les dernières heures avant sa mort dans le sens où ils vont croire qu'il est allé en boîte ils vont demander à plein de gens
de la boîte s'ils ont vu etc ou s'il a fait des trucs bizarres tous les gens de la boîte bondir banon on l'a même
pas vu c'est on danse et on a la tête ailleurs et donc ça les mène à rien et la pelote oui tu as vraiment
des compétences d'enquêteurs qui dépasse complètement cet inspecteur squeeze soyons francs pour lui l'explication la plus logique
c'est que georges se serait rendu à la maison du meurtrier mais on a retrouvé georges
défenestré au pied de chez lui donc c'est à dire qu'ensuite le meurtrier serait allé avec georges chez georges
après avoir buté georges meurtrier serait dit putain peut-être quelqu'un m'a vu ou entendu je suis dans la merde alors il aurait appelé louis c'est
felipe pour leur demander de l'aide
il aurait donc monté ce petit délire de photos pour faire croire que georges était en boîte luis et felipe aurait un alibi de ouf
puisqu'il était
vraiment à la boîte de nuit au moment où georges est mort donc voilà si fier une photo pour rester que dalle puisque leur alibi
en béton il était vraiment pas avec george congé mort mais pourquoi luis et felipe aurait eu intérêt à coopérer avec ce mec dont on
connaît pas le nom qui a buté georges est le point le plus important
pourquoi george va dans la maison du meurtrier au lieu d'aller en boîte rejoindre Luis essayer de le récupérer
bah c'est évident parce que le meurtrier était le nouveau mec de luis
notre ami plot-tuit est donc allé fouiller dans leurs abonnés sur leur compte twitter et il a cherché un mec qui correspond aux caractéristiques
que nous a donné notre ami charles et
bingo il a trouvé qu'un seul utilisateur qui avait un nom étranger et c'est
william et jose la photo de profil bas rupts bingo il a bien les yeux bleus et les cheveux bruns et la petite étincelle dans
le cerveau notre sherlock espagnol et comprend tout luis felipe
williams forment un tandem
sentimental c'est à dire que felipe et william sont amoureux de luis et que luis est amoureux de felipe et william george se fait plaquer
par luiz et luiz n'a pas un nouveau mec mais de nouveau mec
t'as pitcho georges serait donc allé toquer chez williams cette nuit là pour lui dire de rester loin de luis la jalousie on connaît bien
tous mais bon de là à ce que william répondre par le meurtre c'est un peu violent donc peut-être que george aurait menacé avec quelque
chose la théorie de pelote tweet c'est que george aurait en sa possession
des photos de son passé sexuel avec luis et l'aurait menacée williams de les faire tourner si jamais ils n'arrêtaient pas de voir luis qui
aurait à
cfoot eu la frousse et le sommes à williams pour être une grosse merde et tu es georges et c'est comme ça que l'histoire prend
fin braquant pelote widowmaker sherlock
dommage que tout ça soit faut
arrêter je sais que vous avez le sommet vous avec la plupart des threads que j'ai fait c'est sur des trucs fake à 100% mais
comme j'ai déjà dit on s'en fout que je sois faye quand ça nous a bien diverti que c'est bien écrit et là je dis
bravo parce que claude tweetie la chine et mais en plus petit succès déverrouiller pour lui il ya le compte twitter de la police
espagnole le vrai comptes certifiés qui a répondu à son ce raid en disant vos recherches ont confirmé le rapport de nos investigations si vous
êtes victime de ces extorsions la police vous aidera ne cédez pas au chantage c'est magnifique
modesto garcia et le créateur de ce serait donc ces blogs tweets et la crise on serait dans le cas d'un concours pour le festival
fait ryad l île aux espagnols élevé de bonjour et il a gagné le concours et on comprend pourquoi ce serait des fous et en
plus c'est trop bien parce que ça parle d'un sujet qui est beaucoup
d'actualité qui est là les changes de new le chantage avec des photos sexuelle de
souvent de ses ex alors j'en profite aussi pour dire un mot là dessus même si le roi des rats fait une vidéo qui vous
pouvez aller voir et qui parle de ça et qui est très intéressante et c'est horrible ne cédez jamais au chantage
de photos sexuelle ou de vidéos sexuelles de sextape ou je sais pas quoi il ya que les gros gros immense fils de pute pour
faire ça et je le sais vous n'êtes pas les fils de pute alors ne faites pas ça c'est débile et si jamais quelqu'un vous
menace avec ça
parlez-en à la police fait quelque chose mais ne vous laissez pas faire il faut surtout pas rester dans le silence si vous avez des
news de votre copain de votre copine quand vous vous séparez vous voulez supprimer
les partages est passé complètement inadmissible de faire ça ça peut vraiment
détruire des vies de faire ça alors ne le fait pas et encore une fois si vous êtes victime de sa part les ans
police c'est important voilà h couteau j'ai pu parler d'un sujet en plus dont je voulais parler l'oeil et le thread c'était l'occasion d'en parler
génial ce serait du début à la fin il s'était pas aimé le thread si vous a plu si vous en voulez d'autres des différents
etc ça faisait pourtant
jura il est fou si là il est fou je vous dis à bientôt je ne vous dis pas ce que je vais faire en
passant cette porte mais il se peut que ce soit du red dead redemption
Merci d'avoir lu les sous titres :)